His nickname is still known across the globe.
Simon Bolivar arm,
the El Libera Tattoo or the liberator,
the man who almost single handedly arrested South America from Spanish control.
He was without a doubt one of the most important men who ever lived.
A Latino George Washington,
a general who could stand up shoulder to shoulder with Napoleon in his short
life.
He United all of modern Colombia,
Venezuela,
Panama,
and Ecuador into a single superstate and then live long enough to see all his
dreams turn to dust in the harsh daylight of independence.
Soldier,
hero Xr,
radical general dictator,
man of the people,
Simon Bolivar.
He was many things yet outside of Latin America,
knowledge of his life is something most of us are sorely lacking.
Well,
today we're taking you on a sweeping right through the epic life of the man.
No Day history as the liberator.
If you were putting bats on which newborn baby mice grew up to be a
revolutionary in 1783 Caracas,
Simon Bolivar would have been far down your list.
Born into a wealthy Spanish descended family.
Young Boulevard was one of the richest voice in the whole of Venezuela.
But even in these early days,
there were signs that the prince of Caracas didn't lead the easy life.
His position would suggest,
while avant was barely three when his wealthy father died and not yet a 10 when
his mother followed her husband into the grave,
left in the charge of a disinterested uncle boulevard was seen,
dumped upon eight succession of tutors that he did his best to ignore.
With one exception,
Simon Rodriguez shed more than just a first name with boulevard.
He shared the works of John Zachary,
so,
and other icons of liberal thought boulevard often feigned disinterest.
Rodriguez must've gotten something right though.
When he began his Revolutionary Korea,
it would it be these lessons that volleyball would you use as the raw
ingredients of his own political philosophy?
Not anything as coherence as a political philosophy was on bolivares minds at
the time,
cause the 16 year olds,
rich good would seem to be heading off to Europe where I'm like all of
Venezuela's aristocracy.
He would take in the court in Spain,
choir and education,
maybe find a bride and has returned to Caracas,
is ready to join the elite and in a way that's kind of what happens boulevard.
He arrived in Madrid just as the 18th century was drawing to a close.
He spent time at court and married his great love.
This was Maria Teresa Rodriguez del Toro.
He,
Lisa in the parallel universe.
The rest of his biography would probably now read and then he retired to Caracas
and settle into a life of privilege.
So I really hope you liked that video,
but that's not what happens.
Once again,
what looks like an easy existence for boulevard quickly gave way to pain less
than a year after their marriage.
He and Maria Theresa returned to Caracas to settle down,
barely.
Where are they off the boat when Maria Theresa contracted yellow fever and died.
If you're looking for the moment,
Simon Bolivar,
the Prince of Caracas became Simon Boulevard.
The revolutionary this,
this is it.
Boulevard was so distraught by his wife's death that he made a sworn vow to
never marry again,
a vow that he caps for the rest of his life.
He certainly did.
His fair share of sleeping around is he threw himself into politics as a means
of escaping the heartache.
It was this decision that really set him on the path to greatness.
There was one other side effect of Maria Theresa's death in 1804 bollards on
decided to return to Europe.
It was a while back on the old consonants.
This,
he would make another solemn vow,
one which would have repercussions for centuries to come.
In 1804 France was in the grip of a national awakening following the extreme
bloodshed of the revolution.
A new general has risen up to set the nation back on track.
He was seeing by liberal radicals across the world is almost a secular seconds
coming and enlightens mountain who's destruction of the older order was ushering
in a new and greater age.
As you've probably already guessed that general's name.
Well,
it was Napoleon Bonaparte Ans Boulevard was in fraud as to what he had achieved
with France rather than returns of the suffocating order of Madrid boulevard,
decided to set sail to France to see this in lightens up hovel fast hands.
If Boulevard had hopes of being inspired by Napoleon,
they've he was quickly disappointed boulevard.
Now,
a young man reached Paris just as Napoleon was crowning himself emperor and
transforming from an enlightened despot into a straight up death spots.
Outrage did this naked power grab boulevard closed the windows of his Paris
apartment in protest on the day of the coronation refusing to join in the
revelries.
Disgusted by Spain,
disappointed by Napoleonic France.
Polyvore spend the next few years aimlessly drifting around Europe,
trudging the well-trodden root of the grand talk.
It was while on this trip he bumps into his old tutor,
Simon Rodriguez.
Rodriguez had long since then exiled from Venezuela for his radicalism.
The two they went to Italy together at some point.
Rodriquez seems to have lit the flame of independence in Bolivares soul because
when they reached Graham Boulevard claims at the top,
if the Aventine Hill,
one of the seven hills upon which the Great Roman Republic was founded there,
he swore a solemn vow to never rest until South America was free from Spanish
control.
It was the second grade val.
The boulevard would succeed in keeping,
yeah,
around the time that boulevard was traipsing around Italy,
two major things happens that would make bolivares val look laughably naive and
just as quickly make it look very prescient.
The first came in 1806 when they liberal radical known as Francisco de Miranda
rationally decided now was the time for South American independence and
Venezuelan patriots.
Miranda is today known as the precursor,
the man who preceded the liberator,
but what are boulevards name would become synonymous with success.
Miranda's became rather associated with catastrophe in the summer of 1806
Moran's at tried to launch a general uprising and Venezuela landing a partially
us funded small force on the country's coast,
but rather than flocking to his side,
ordinary Venezuelans caps out of the way as a Spanish forced to send it
capturing nearly the entire expedition.
Miranda,
you barely escaped with his life at the time it looked like the end of the
independent stream.
Venezuelans had been given a chance to rise up and they decided to lie low.
But then the second major thing happens that it blew the question open once
again in 1808 and Napoleon depose the king of Spain and installed his brother
Joseph on the Spanish throne for Venezuelans already uncomfortable with Spanish
rule.
This just far too much South America,
it exploded in revolts.
Newly arrived back in his hometown boulevard quickly decided these antique
French uprisings were the perfect vehicle for his patriotic dreams initially on
the sidelines of the action and correct because a lot of art students stage to
take over a group known as the Patriotic Society for the development of
agriculture.
And livestock and turning it into a hotbed of revolutionary activity.
While many of his contemporaries felt he was too radical boulevard,
nonetheless maters influenced,
felt.
It was following a stirring speech of his to Congress that Venezuela declared
independence on April the 19th 1810 and on the boulevard was anywhere close to
the true levers of power caps on a short leash.
It was only as personal wealth that got him an official position in the new
government as an ambassador to Britain,
while they're boulevard managed to convince the exiled Francisco de Miranda to
return to lead Venezuela registration that he would later regret when Miranda
wrote his flair for catastrophe or with him.
Now a whole books could be written on why Miranda was the wrong man for the job.
Here he was a poor general who allows royalist forces to maintain footholds in
the young country.
It was also a poor judge of talents in sidelines tacticians Lincoln Boulevard in
favor of weaker leaders.
On top of all that,
he was poor in a crisis.
When an earthquake flattens Karaca sin 1812 Miranda failed to control the
narrative that God was punishing the upstart Venezuelans for defying the Spanish
crown.
Although bolivares acquitted himself well digging through the rubble of Caracas
with his bare hands to rescue survivors public feeling the gams are turning
against the Republicans.
By summer of 1812 Venezuela was in revolt again this time against Miranda
Bolivar and they're failed.
Republic [inaudible] trying to staunch the tides by setting himself up as a
dictator.
But now the writing,
it was on the wall.
In August,
Rhonda snapped at bolted.
He was caught by Bolivar and other Republican soldiers trying to board a British
ship with the contents of the Venezuelan treasury and incensed boulevard hands.
It is asked to our friends over to the Spaniards before fleeing into exile
himself as he sailed away from Venezuela boulevard left behind the ruins of a
republic that had collapsed after only a year burying his dreams just as the
great earthquake it buried Caracas.
Just as with the earthquake.
If boulevard wanted to salvage anything from this catastrophe,
he was going to have to roll up his sleeves and personally start
digging.
It was wild and Exxon and Catia Heena,
which is today in Columbia that boulevard did,
is metaphorical digging for Muncie,
analyze the failures of the first Venezuelan republic determines to rescue some
lessons from the rubble.
The results was his l manifesto,
Dikata Haina,
the Carter Hannah Manifesto,
which today reads like a cheat sheet for understanding Bolivarian Thought
Boulevards decided the main thing wrong with Venezuela was its lack of a strong
government.
Although he pinpointed the failure of Miranda to root out all raw list forces
and the creation of a federalist rather than a centralist republic.
He also made vague noises about invading Venezuela and restoring independence,
but nobody in content.
Pena thought Hetero rarely do it.
How wrong they were.
In winter of 1812 boulevard went seriously off.
Scripts commissioned into the new Granada Rami,
and given a small and garrison,
he suddenly abandoned his post and took his men on a suicidal charge up the
Magdalena River.
The challenge being aimed at the royalist.
Fourth is that still controlled most of the country.
It should have been the end of boulevard,
but instead it was his making bolivares blitzkrieg annihilated the Spanish low
forces stations along the river,
overwhelmed and terrified.
They simply abandoned town.
After town was boulevard came roaring through.
By the end of January,
the entire river was in Patriot hands.
It was a resounding victory for the independence movement he had to.
Bolivar wasn't even close to being done like a man possessed.
He ended the Magdalena campaign,
not with a well absorbed arrest,
but with the invasion of Venezuela.
The invasion today is known as the admirable campaign,
but make no mistake,
the admirable part certainly doesn't refer to Bolivares conduct.
Desperate to be the ones and liberate Venezuela and Restore The republic
boulevard resorted to some very dirty tricks.
Chief among them was the decree of war to the death,
which stated that any native Spaniards who did not actively help them liberate
Venezuela would be executed on the spot.
Whatever the legalities of Bolivares semi genocide or decree,
it certainly worked as a second uprising.
Gripped Venezuela's east boulevard rampage across its West liberating city after
city justice he had done on the Magdalena campaign.
By July,
royalist forces were collapsing under the unsought by August.
Resistance said simply melted away.
On August the sixth 1893 Simon Boulevard marched into Caracas and declared a new
republic barely a year before he had fled the city.
As his dreams collapsed.
Now he was resurrecting them from the ashes.
The admirable campaign remains one of the greatest military victories in all of
history,
and about half a year,
bolivares single handedly destroyed the royalist upper hand in Grand Colombia
and free Venezuela from Spanish rule.
It's one of the main reasons his name still carries a significant way today.
Unfortunately,
it also sowed the seeds of the second republics destruction out on the plains of
Venezuela,
news of boulevards,
Walker,
I'm is reached the bandits and the cowboys under the leadership of Pro Spanish
psychopath,
hosay,
Tom and Bob as these disparate groups United into a force of Auntie Bolivar,
vengeance,
they were called the legions of hell,
the Isis of their day.
The legions of how glorified in the rape,
mutilation,
torture,
and massacring of anyone who stood in their way off to boulevard is a victory.
They swept across Venice sweater with such ferocity.
Even the liberator stood no chance.
Caracas fell in an orgy of blood in July,
1814 and boulevard fled back to new Granada.
I need to find royalist forces in the sense although he would launch a
successful campaign against separatists in Bogota.
Bolivares time was over by May,
1850 and even Carta Haina has turned against the hero of Magdalena and spot
Lavar.
He was forced to flee to Jamaica once again watching from the ship as the
fairness.
Wade and republican burns and his victories collapsed into dust.
Most men would have given up at this point,
but most men are not.
Simon Boulevard
it was wall and recalibrating in is Axon in British Jamaica,
but the liberator wrote the Second Grade Bolivarian taxed the letter from
Jamaica along cry for liberty and freedom.
The letter is today notable for one very important passage.
Sang American natives lacks the virtue for democracy due to centuries of Spanish
oppression.
Boulevard declared a free South America would need a strong hand at the wheel.
Uh,
presidents for life.
There was the first inkling that the world has of the liberator's hidden
dictatorial tendencies,
but the latter.
It was only seen ominous in hindsight.
For now,
boulevard was an outcast watching his country plunge into a vicious civil war.
He needed to get back to Venezuela and he needed to do it fast.
But luckily help us on hand from a surprising source.
A decade earlier,
Haiti has thrown off.
It's French shackles and declared itself free.
The only successful slave rebellion in modern history as a plantation owner,
Balaban was himself a slave or something that should have put him at odds with
Haiti's governments.
It might've were it not for Haitian.
President Alexander Patty on in 1815 boulevard met with patty on to discuss
South American independence.
Patty on promised the revolutionary guns,
money,
ships,
and support for free in Venezuela.
But there was a condition.
Bolivar would have to swear to free all of the slaves in South America starting
with his own.
The deal is controversial today because while boulevard did give up his own
slaves,
he never forced any of his fellow Ridge Venezuelans to follow suit.
Regardless,
Bolivares word was enough and the Haitian presidents equips the liberator for
war for the third time in a decade,
but it's our returns to Venezuela to free it from royalist hands,
but first there would be a grinding war of attrition for three years,
Valvar made as many losses as he did.
Gains while Haitian money kept his army,
a flow to the royalists was simply too strong to dislodge in this long period.
Perhaps the only real victory boulevard had was convincing who San Antonio
payers to join him.
A cowboy in the grasslands.
Payers had raised his own anti-rail list army from the remnants of the legions
of how it would be his men that would help ensure bolivares victory,
but only after boulevard had proved himself worthy of them before he deferred to
the liberator.
Pat has challenged him to a series of physical feats culminating in a nonstop
all night ride that depend on us as amazements went home so long he christened
Bolivar ins in 1819 the war was in stalemate.
Then in spring ins had a brainwave with Ryan.
This is focused on defending Caracas.
Why not attack the Vice Regal Capitol of Bogota?
No one had the tanks before because it was separated by an impossible line of
mountains.
No one has even bothered to defend these only bolivar.
He didn't think that these mountains where as impossible as everyone seemed to
think and to May you set out to prove it.
The going was beyond tough.
Roaring rivers,
miles of flooded plains and torrential storms had to be braved before bolivares
army even reached the Andes.
Then the soldiers had to India a grueling 13,000 foot climb and a march through
the snow and the ice.
By the time the reached new Granada to thousands of his men would debt,
but it had been worth it with the Spanish.
Assuming no army would be insane enough to try and cross the Andes.
The road to Bogota was wide open.
The moments boulevard descended from the mountains.
It was game over one Spanish general.
A guy called Barry Arrow stood in his way and it's boulevard made absolute
mincemeat of him at the battle of biocar bolivar and Neha later the writer's
troops in under two hours suffering only 66 casualties to bury arrows,
nearly two thousands then he marched straight devote guitar just four days
earlier.
New Granada had been under Spanish control and now it was in the hands of
boulevard.
Boulevard's march across the Andes changed the course of history.
He installed himself as dictator of new Granada.
Now renames grand Colombia and set about rebuilding his army with momentum on
Bolivares side was nothing that the remaining Spanish forces could do.
After an awkward six months,
[inaudible] Boulevard marched back into Venezuela on June the 24th 1821 the
royalists were Naya lated with a revolution in Spain,
meaning no new trips would be coming to help the remaining royalists.
They simply gave up by August Boulevard,
had done it the thing he'd sworn to do in Rome or those years ago after his
third liberation.
Venezuela would never again be under Spanish control as a joy,
as Bolivar folded as homeland into his new Grand Columbian superstate.
He must've thought his story had finally ended.
Unfortunately though for history,
it's still had one final depressing chapter.
Over the next few years.
The remaining provinces of Spanish South America were liberated in 1822
bolivares protege,
Antonio Jose to sucrose and liberated Ecuador in 1824 boulevard and secretes
together liberated Peru.
Half a year later they liberated upper Peru,
which we're so grateful that it immediately renamed itself.
Bolivia.
Ecuador was folded into Grand Colombia while Peru named boulevard dictator for
life.
The Spanish were gone and boulevard rules half of South America and it was that
last part there was about to become a serious problem.
If Boulevard was a great general,
he was not such a great dictator.
He wasted money constantly on military expeditions and every time one of his
underlings trying to press through unnecessary structural reforms.
A lot of our with next them leaving the economy.
Evening Mass.
On top of that,
he kept trying to force all of the countries had liberated to accept being a
part of Grand Colombia when it was plainly obvious that new Granada,
Ecuador,
Venezuela,
Peru,
all wanted to go their separate ways back in Venezuela,
payers was even threatening to succeed fearing a civil war.
Bolivar abandons Peru and rotor back to Bogota and only for Peru to invade
Ecuador in his absence as boulevard trying to hold ground Columbia together,
he began assuming more and more powers until just like Napoleon,
he to flee transitions from enlightened despot to just plain old desk.
Spot effigy is where burns of him in the streets.
When he tried to have a new constitution written,
it wound up being so liberal that Bolivar instead ignore this and held onto his
powers.
By 1828 he was so unpopular that he was very nearly assassinated in Bogota and
had to spend hours hiding in a ditch in order to evade capture,
despised in his new home,
his health beginning to fail.
In 1829 Balboa was forced to watch as payers succeeded from Grand Colombia
creating the state of Venezuela.
As he did so,
he issued a decree that boulevard should be executed if he ever set foot in the
country again now also cut off from his homelands.
The liberator fell into a deep depression is correct as the states were
confiscated by payers as new governments leaving him penniless or revolutionary
ghost haunting the streets of Boca type.
Finally,
Bolivia excepted the inevitable and went into exile as interacts from Bogota to
the coastie received news that Ecuador had succeeded and that his protege suit
gray had been assassinated,
broken,
miserable,
despised,
and dying from tuberculosis.
While I finally wound up in the house of a Spanish admirer and the coastal city
of Santa Marta,
although his hosts sense for the best doctors in America,
it was useless.
At the end of 1830 all of our board boarded is final boat into the lung exile of
death.
As he slipped away from the shores of the living,
it's possible he looked back and felt familiar.
Sadness once again,
Grand Colombia lay in ashes.
His dreams,
where ruins,
I need this time.
There'd be no coming back,
no more chances.
As Boulevard sailed away into endless night,
he did so.
A sad and a broken man.
Although Boulevard Deiter hated tyrants today he is regarded as one of the
greatest men Latin America ever produced.
While Venezuela is now a basket case,
Colombia,
Ecuador and Peru are functioning democratic states in perfect.
The liberating may have been,
but there's no doubting Simon bolivares military genius or the strength of his
vision.
A few people can ever be said to have truly changed history,
but bolivar is one of them.
So I already have you found the video.
Interesting.
If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button below.
It doesn't really do much,
but it does make us feel good.
Let us know that you're liking this video.
Also,
why not use the comments?
They'll let us know what you think or a drop a suggestion down there for a
future biographics why not?
And subscribe if you like these biographies.
We do them twice a week on Mondays and Thursdays.
So,
uh,
hit that subscribe button and the little bell thing.
If you actually want to hear about these videos,
because as I say,
every time,
subscribe doesn't really do what it used to.
So hit the bell and as always,
thank you for watching.